[Applause]
you know you're looking at the first
ever photo of Jupiter's North Pole
stunning isn't it the image is courtesy
of the Juno spacecraft which made its
first fly by of the gas giant not only
is it a beautiful scene but it doesn't
look anything like the rest of the
planet
its clouds are bluer than elsewhere for
instance the North Pole also seems to be
surprisingly stormy and the clouds here
might be casting shadows suggesting that
they're flying at a higher altitude than
the surrounding bits that's because the
Sun is still hitting the clouds even as
it's setting now Jupiter's gas giant
cousin Saturn has this huge hexagon
formation at its North Pole but not
Jupiter why that'll be a mystery Juno
might help to unravel Juno isn't just
snapping photos in visible light it's
packed with all manner of other
instruments
check out this infrared shot of the
Aurora at Jupiter's South Pole Juno has
also picked up the Aurora's radio
signals this haunting wail is what it
sounds like when you convert those
signals to noise so all told the
spacecraft will do three dozen more
close approaches so get ready to see a
lot more of Jupiter in the coming months
hello beautiful